bonjour et bienvenue dans Europe Hebdo
au Parlement européen à Bruxelles
émission spéciale avec nous deux poids
lourds de la vie politique européenne
Daniel conbendit et gu ver Hofstad ils
ne sont pas du même bord mais ils ont
écrit un livre ensemble sur l'Europe
fédérale et la première question que
nous poserons à nos invités est celle du
budget européen qui va payer pour
l'Europe
900 960 990 1000 milliards d'euros
combien d'argent pour le budget européen
enjeu fixer l'enveloppe financière pour
les 7 prochaines années la bataille est
lancée il y a ceux qui veulent dépenser
plus une alliance de 15 pays emmené par
la Pologne la Grèce l'Estonie ou encore
Malte et qui refuse que les fonds
européens ne fassent les frais de
l'austérité et puis il y a ceux qui au
contraire ne veulent pas donner 1 € de
plus parmi eux la France l'Allemagne la
Finlande le Danemark le Royaume-Uni ou
encore les Pays-Bas la plupart sont
contributeurs net au budget c'està-dire
qu'il mettent plus d'argent que les
autres au pot commun le Premier ministre
néerlandais explique que son pays a pris
des mesures drastiques pour contrer la
crise et que la rigueur s'applique à
tous David Cameron menace de son côté de
sortir son veto si le budget augmente
même la Commission européenne a proposé
de baisser l'enveloppe de 50 milliards
d'euros mais si le budget est réduit il
n'y aura plus d'argent pour financer
tous les programmes européens en même
temps la politique agricole commune le
Fond Social Européen même Erasmus est
menacé de disparition et bientôt il n'y
aura plus d'argent pour l'aide
alimentaire réservée au plus démunis ni
même pour les fonctionnaires européens
qui ont battu le pavé à Bruxelles alors
s'il n'y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses qui va payer pour
l'Europe alors qui va payer pour
l'Europe c'est la question du moment que
nous allons Katia poser à nos deux
invités deux invités exceptionnels Guy
verofstad bonjour vous êtes président
ici de l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'Europe vous avez été
Premier ministre belge pendant près de
10 ans et Daniel conbendit co-président
je nai jamais été premier
ministre coprésident du groupe des vers
et vous avez écrit à quatre mains cet
ouvrage debout l'Europe un cri qui
s'adresse aux gouvernants et également
aux citoyens européens un appel à créer
une véritable fédération européenne
sinon dites-vous l'Europe dans 10 15 ans
n'existera plus alors GUF rstad le
budget européen c'est l'actualité du
moment on voit que les dirigeants
européens et d'ailleurs le Parlement
européen s'écharpe ils ne sont pas
d'accord est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est symptomatique d'un problème au
niveau européen aujourd'hui il faut
naturellement reconnaître que chaque
chaque fois quand il y a un budget il y
a la la lutte entre les États d'une part
et certains états entre eux et et et le
Parlement européen ce que le Parlement
européen veut surtout se créer de
changer le budget d'e d'une façon très
importante très radicale c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des ressources propres à
l'intérieur du budget ça veut dire que
les citoyens d'orén avant vont payer
directement à l'Union européenne plutôt
que de passer par des contributions
nationales le problème c'est que les
États européens ne veulent pas de ça je
sais pas il y a beaucoup de de des États
qui sont en faveur aussi de ça ce que
parce que si vous avez des ressources
propres donc une sorte de financement
direct du citoyen vers l'Union
européenne alors les contributions
nationales peuvent baisser peuvent être
diminué alors quand on voit Daniel
conite les déclarations des dirigeants
européens François Hollande qui a dit il
faut plus d'Europe et cetera et quand on
voit que ici en fait personne ne veut
payer pour ce plus d'Europe c'est quelle
est votre réaction attention il y a
d'abord ce que vous ce que vous on ne
voit pas assez de l'extérieur
une véritable rupture à
l'intérieur du Conseil européen vous
avez les 15 pays 15 pays sur 27 qui sont
les les pays des fonds de cohésion qui
sont radicalement contre la position
anglaise et contre la positionition
allemande et ils ne savent pas trop bien
quelle est la position française mais
donc c'est pas vrai que c'est le
Parlement contre les
gouvernements jamais disons les tensions
à l'intérieur du conseil ont été aussi
fortes je parle
sous le contrôle de gu qui lui a fait
partie du conseil mais c'est vrai ça on
le voit qu'il a eu hier une réunion de
15 chefs de gouvernement des pays des
fonds de cohésion à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte du Parlement
européen ça veut bien dire que donc
c'est pas simplement Parlement contre
conseil
deuxièmement il faut comprendre que pour
certains pays le budget européen c'est
le seul moyen de relancer de redéployer
l'économie
pour certains évidemment pas pour un
pays comme l'Allemagne ou la France mais
pour certains pays c'est le budget
européen avec les fonds de cohésion qui
est le seul moyen de relancer c'est pour
cela et qui a raison la taxe sur les
transactions financières la taxe sur les
c'est des ressources propres pour le pro
et ça fait baisser la contribution
nationale des pays qui justement lèvent
une taxe sur les transactions aussi
augmenter le contrôle du citoyen parce
que si le citoyens doit payer
directement à l'Union européenne il va
être intéressé ce qui se passe avec son
argent il va y avoir une contrôle
beaucoup plus intense des citoyens
envers l'Union européenne donc aussi au
niveau de la démocratie c'est un énorme
pas en avant cette idée des ressources
propres mais quand même aujourd'hui ce
qu'on constate c'est une division assez
forte entre ces deux camps dont vous
parlez ce que vous pensez que ils sont
en train de se disputer il faut le dire
sur 1 % 1 % c'est quoi comparez ça avec
les États-Unis les États-Unis ont un
budget de 24 % de leur produits
intérieur brut moi je pense que c'est
justement le fait qu'on a un un budget
aussi inimportant et qui est la cause de
notre crise autour de l'euro parce que
l'euro est soutenu par quoi l'union
monétaire est soutenue par quoi par par
rien du tout il n'y a pas d'autorité
fédérale derrière il n'y a pas de budget
il n'y a pas de marché obligataire
derrière donc le fait qu'on se dispute
sur un budget d' environ 1 % et que les
États-Unis ont 24 fois un budget plus
important c'est ça aussi le cœur de de
de de la crise autour de l'UR alors
l'Europe fédérale vous avez prononcé le
mot c'est ce que vous défendez dans dans
le livre que vous avez écrit ensemble
alors que vous n'êtes pas du même bord
politique alors nous sommes rendus ici
au Parlement européen et nous avons
demandé à certains de vos collègues
députés européens ce qu'il pensait de
votre ouvrage regardez c'est un
reportage signé thba
lefloc cher Katia cher François
aujourd'hui je suis parti à la pêche non
pas ce genre de pêche mais plutôt à la
pêche au députés et ceci est mon
amçon moi je viens voir les députés pour
leur demander est-ce que oui vous aussi
vous voulez une Europe fédérale ou non
surtout pas il nous faut un échelon
pouvoir fédéral au niveau européen pour
moi il y a pas de
douttion en thorie tout le monde est
pour le fédéralisme mais en réalité mais
en réalité quand on met le sujet sur la
table c'est là que les problèmes commen
pourquoi on n pas encore d'Europe
fédérale peut-être parce qu'on n pas
encore une crise jusqu'à ce moment mais
mais au moment de crise on voit que il
faut bien le faire si c'est tout
fédéralisé pour faire la même chose pour
continuer à mener les mêmes politiques
qui nous mènent dans le mur ben l'Europe
ira simplement plus vite dans le mur
voilà Angela Merkel on va voir si elle a
lu le livre ça va
difficile désolé Daniel vre compatriote
n'a pas voulu de votre livre on a
essayé vous avez lu ce
livre non non désolé je suis
pressé
ok dommage eux proposent un gouvernement
européen avec des ministres européens et
même un président européen élu par T
tous les Européens c'est quelque chose
qui vous réjouit ou pas c'est beaucoup
trop vite à mon avis alors eux le
proposent pour pourquoi pas DESS 2014
c'est beaucoup trop vite
aussi je suis totalement contre le
fédéralisme car nous avons des cultures
trop différentes les Allemands ne seront
jamais comme les Grecs et les Grecs
comme les
Allemands l'ADN européen bon c'est un
peu barocque hein et pour finir nous
sommes allés parler fédéralisme avec le
chef de fil des
eurosceptique pour l'amour du ciel nous
ne pouvons pas avoir une Europe où la
Grèce et l'Allemagne partagent la même
monnaie
en fait ce n'est pas un système fédéral
qu'il propose c'est une forme d'union
centralisée avec un gouvernement qui
n'est pas démocratique vous êtes dur
c'est ça qu'il propose ce qu'ils
appellent de leur vœux c'est que les
institutions de Bruxelles dont la
plupart des dirigeants ne sont pas élus
et d'immense pouvoir au détriment des
états au final ce sont de dangereux
fanatiqu oui des fanatiques dangereux en
fait ce sont eux les nationalistes des
euronationalistes rien les arrêtera tant
qu'ils n'auront pas leur
empire ah oui l'Empire carrément j'ai
l'impression messieurs que pour
convaincre vos collègues du bien fondé
et du fédéralisme il faudra vraiment que
la force soit avec
vous alors on a entendu ces réactions
mitigées certains ont peur certains
parlent de que vous dites que vous êtes
de dangereux fédéraliste qu'est-ce que
vous leur
répondez moi ça me fait pas peur vous
savez si farad j'aurais dit que il est
d'accord avec nous je me suicide tout de
suite he c'est il y a quelque chose qui
marche pas non mais c'est évident que
lui c'est un un un nationaliste et
d'ailleurs je crois que il veut que
l'Angleterre sorte de l'Union
européenne peut-être que c'est la
solution pour l'Angleterre et comme ça
on sera
débarrassé du chantage permanent qu'on
font les gouvernements anglais et que ça
soit un gouvernement d'ailleurs
social-démocrate anglais ou conservateur
c'est toujours le chantage face à
l'Europe et puis deuxièmement on veut
pas c'est pas vrai on l'explique on veut
pas un super état l'État fédéral c'est
autre chose mais surtout il faut savoir
ce qu'on veut dans 30 ans plus aucun
pays de l'Union européenne ne fera
partie du G8 et c'est les autres c'est
les autres les vrais empires qui nous
domineront que ça soit la Chine que ça
soit les États-Unis même le Brésil et ça
et donc il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
c'est tout alors vous parler d'utopie
plausible qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vous dites c'est quand même une utopie
mais elle est plausible ça veut dire que
évidemment se projette dans l'avenir et
on sait que l'Europe fédérale elle
viendra pas tout de suite c'est pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas vrai ce que dit
votre journaliste qu'on a dit qu'on veut
le faire en 2014 les journalistes ne
devrai pas dire n'importe quoi non plus
même quand il interie oui mais c'est pas
la même chose c'est pas du tout la même
chose je veux dire il faut changer les
traités ça va c'est un processus mais
c'est un on a on est dans le brouillard
et là maintenant on a une boussole vous
donnez un cap et on dit voilà c'est vers
là alors ça mettra 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans
mais on sait que les perspectives c'est
l'Europe fédérale moi j'aimerais
comprendre pardonocha o où vous voulez
aller exactement parce que derrière le
mot Europe fédéral on peut mettre
effectivement tout tout ce qu'on veut ça
serait quoi ça serait c'est c'est mettre
en place un gouvernement européen qui
est responsable devant le Parlement
européen d'une part et devant une
deuxième chambre qui sera une chambre
qui va représenter les états nation de
de l'Union européenne c'est'est créé
aussi un trésorerie tésorerie européenne
un ministre des Finances européen mais
c'est allé aussi plus loin un marché
obligataire européen la défense
européenne parce qu'on pense que ce
serait beaucoup mieux d'avoir l'armée
européenne et et et puis c'est créé
naturellement une une force au niveau
euh de de du monde au niveau mondial qui
peut faire regagner la souverainité pour
les citoyens européens parce qu'il faut
le dire aujourd'hui le problème dans le
monde globalisé d'aujourd'hui c'est que
les gens ont peur de ne pas de plus
avoir leur destin en main et bien
l'Europe fédérale permet euh de garantir
la souverainité pas au niveau euh
national où on l'a perdu pour le moment
mais le de le regagner au niveau
européen qu'est-ce qui resterait au
niveau national justement beaucoup de
choses de de toute l'implémentation
l'exécution euh de toutes les stratégies
qui ont été convenues au niveau fédéral
au niveau européen donc ça reste les
États-nations ne vont pas disparaître
mais on dit que c'est au niveau européen
qu'il faut créer une démocratie
européenne une stratégie économique
européenne parce qu'autrement on va
jamais sortir de la crise le problème de
la crise autour de l'euro aujourd'hui
c'est que on a 17 gouvernements
différents 17 ministres des Finances
différents 17 marchés obligatoire et que
ça ne peut pas marcher l'école la santé
la culture enfin il y a il y a y a
d'énormes disons espaces politiques qui
ne seront pas réglés au niveau fédéral
mais est-ce que vous pensez que le
citoyen est prêt à à répondre présent à
votre appel est-ce que est-ce que quand
on a fait les Traités de Rome est-ce que
quand ils ont commencé à à se par les
Français les Allemands dans les années
50 est-ce que les Français étaient prêts
à faire la paix comme ça avec les
Allemands non aujourd'hui nous en tant
que responsable politique on dit il faut
proposer quelque chose aux citoyens pour
faire avancer le chmilblic et il est
évident que les les citoyens aujourd'hui
quand on le parle de l'Europe fédérale
ils disent qu'est-ce que c'est avec
raison et c'est pour ça qu'on a écrit ce
livre pour dire va expliquer quelle est
notre vision de l'Europe fédérale et
puis il faut gagner il faut conquérir
les citoyens c'est ça la politique et
aussi instaurer un véritable contrôle
démocratique qui naturement parce qu'
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup trop d'hommes
politiques en Europe qui suivent
simplement l'opinion publique et qu'il
se disent bah l'opinion publique est
eurosceptique ou est farouchement
populiste nationaliste alors je deviens
aussi nationaliste PIST regardez ce que
ça donne avec la Grèce et l'Allemagne et
les pays on suit le café du commerce et
donc on dit non non non et on fait le
contraire mais on est obligé de le faire
en catimidie on dit jamais la vérité on
veut pas dire oui la Grèce aura besoin
aujourd'hui d'un rééchelonnement de la
dette on veut pas le dire on va perdre
des milliards parce qu'on ose pas le
dire et cetera donc nous on veut on on
on on comprend notre rôle en tant que
disons responsable politique de proposer
et de se battre pour des idée alors ça
vous êtes dans votre rôle parce que vous
j'ai envie de dire vous vous bousculez
les choses gu verochcha vous avez été
premier ministre alors d'un état un
petit peu particulier puce que j'ai
envie de dire il est fédéraliste dans
l'âme c'est c'est la Belgique mais
est-ce que vous pouvez comprendre par
exemple qu'un qu'un François Hollande
qui vient d'être élu à la tête de de de
la République française et du mal à dire
bon écoutez moi je vais perdre une
partie de mes pouvoirs vous m'avez élu
pour quelque chose et de toute façon on
va rapidement transférer ça au niveau au
niveau européen est-ce il a entendu tout
d'abord on demande pas à la France de
devenir un État fédéral hein donc c'est
pas ça qu'on demande on demande de
coopérer ensemble avec la France pour
faire de l'Union européenne une une
organisation fédérale c'est ça qu'on
veut faire et deuxièmement c'est
toujours difficile naturellement de de
de des des des pouvoirs à une autre
instance par exemple supranationale même
si est démocratique mais on n pas le
choix dans le monde de demain c'est
comme Dani l'a dit tantôt dans le G8 de
demain il n'y a aucun pays européen qui
va encore être représenté le JI de
demain c'est quoi c'est la Russie c'est
les États-Unis le Japon la Chine l'Inde
le Brésil et puis le Mexique et
l'Indonésie voilà le J de demain donc si
on veut encore compter si on veut encore
défendre nos intérêts notre modèle
social euh au niveau mondial il faut le
faire ensemble dans une union fédérale
votre question il y avait une erreur
chercheer l'erreur l'erreur c'est que la
France croit avoir aujourd'hui le
président de la France une souveraineté
internationale qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a
plus même vous voyez même dans
l'intervention en Libye hein la France
et l'Angleterre au bout d'une semaine
ils avaient plus de munition ils ont
demand ils ont dû demander aux Anglais
et aujourd'hui la France n'a pas
l'argent pour avoir euh la
l'armée d'intervention nécessaire dans
certains conflits donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui cette idée de la France
parce que la France et au Conseil de
sécurité ou à disons la défense atomique
ça tout ça c'est c'est du blabla c'est
fini et c'est ça qu'il faut expliquer au
français pouvoir n'est plus à Paris ou
ailleurs d'ailles le le le pouvoir n'est
plus dans une capitale européenne elle
est dans une capitale commune le pouvoir
on le peut l'avoir en commun on peut
conquérir nos souveraineté en commun où
on la perd de plus en plus alors
l'Europe existe-t-elle encore sur la
scène internationale entre la toute
puuissance chinoise et américaine
reste-t-il une place pour l'Union
européenne réponse avec ce zapping des
télé
eururopéennes dans les institutions
européennes on espère que cette
réélection permettra de boucler l'accord
de libre échange entre les 27 et les
États-Unis mais les relations sous le
premier mandat d'Obama n'ont pas
toujours étéid
de temps en temps nous avons senti une
certaine fatigue dans la relation entre
l'Union européenne et les
États-Unis une fatigue ressentie aussi
outre atlantique à l'égard d'Européen
jugé trop divisé la nouvelle
administration Obama pourrait deslor
s'avérer plus
exigeante Obama Jing ping les maîtres du
monde et l'Europe dans tout cela nothing
rien en
anglais rien en chinois pas un mot dans
le discours d'Obama mardi soir pas plus
que durant toute la campagne signe du
déclin de l'Europe certains disent même
de sa
décadence jusque là nous avons toujours
eu les États-Unis de notre côté Barack
Obama et le secrétaire d'État au Trésor
Timothy gner soutiennent nos position
notre volonté d'avoir un euro fort de
consolider la monnaie unique et de
garder la Grèce dans la zone
euro l'Amérique qui se profile dans les
années 2015 2025 ce sera une Amérique
qui n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
celle de
1945 c'est une Amérique qui va se
replier de plus en plus et qui va
revenir à à la stabilisation de la de la
montée en puissance chinoise et de la
stabilisation de l'Asie donc il y aura
moins d'Amérique en
Europe alors VO donc la réalité est est
là on l'entend
avec est-ce que vous pensez que le
déclin de l'Europe a déjà commencé c'est
pas le
déclin c'est qu'on n pas assz augmenté
en puissance on n'est pas en déclin
l'Europe aujourd'hui est
bloquée on a fait des pas en avant c'est
Union européenne existe l'Europe les les
États membres aujourd'hui ne sont plus
dans l'état où on était en 1945 ou en
1950 mais maintenant il faut faire un un
troisème saut en avant donc je c'est pas
vrai qu'il y a un déclat on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le monde change et dans
ce monde qui change il faut que l'Europe
change aussi est-ce que le changement
c'est pas aussi un ch
j'ai envie de dire de leader de leader
politique on parlait tout à l'heure du
contrôle démocratique est-ce que vous
pensez que les citoyens européens ont
envie par exemple d'être dirigé par José
Manuel Baroso ou herman van RPU ça n'a
rien de personnel est-ce que mais est-ce
que ces
institutions avait envie d'être dirigé
par Sarkozy non il avent quand même voté
pour lui oui mais après ils ont pas voté
pour lui non mais personne n'a voté pour
jeter dans le petit livre qu'on a écrit
ensemble on propose justement une une
procédure pour cela c'est une réforme où
le président de la commission le
président du conseil ce serait serait
fusionné ce serait le même poste le même
mandat deuxièmement ce serait élu si
possible directement par par tous les
citoyens européenes et puis il y aura
des listes transnationales la
possibilité aussi d'envoyer envers le
Parlement européen des gens aussi élus
par des citoyen donc la démocratie
européenne il faut la créer parce
qu'elleexiste elle existe pour le moment
c'est le Parlement européen mais n pas
mais on peut on peut remédier facilement
à tout ça hein vous faites alors c'est
une des propositions on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur toutes les propositions
mais vous dites vous faites les
élections européennes vous faites
lesélections par list comme vous l'avez
maintenant et vous avez une un deuxième
bulletin et avec ce bulletin vous en
même temps la même élection vous allez
élire le président de la commission et
de l'Europe hein donc vous avez un
bulletin et alors là il y aura une
légitimité il y aura un deuxième tour
après 15 jours après mais vous aurez une
légitimité du président de l'Union
européenne élu au suffrage universel en
même temps que l'élection parlementaire
donc pas comme en France il y a prè il y
a domination de l'une élection sur
l'autre et bien vous auriez alors un
sursaut démocratique de l'Europe par
exemple est-ce qu'il se trouverait une
personnalité comme ça européenne capable
de susciter l'adhésion deun maximum de
citoyensstad ou dan on serait pas
d'accord on serait pas d'accord ça
serait d'ailleurs un débat intéressant
vous êtes candidat tous les deux ah s'il
y avait une élection c'est le seul moi
je dis que ser plus candidat mais si par
hasard si par hasard il décidait qu'il y
ait une élection en même temps directe
au suffrage universel du président l
lion moi je suis candidat je suis
candidat je serai candidat je serai
candidat en Grèce sur une liste
parlementaire et je serai candidat pour
être président de l'chad vous serez
candidat Bahi je serai candidat en tout
cas maintenant pendant les élections
européennes de 2014 mais c'est vrai que
il y a une faiblesse pour le moment de
la Commission européenne dans tout le
travail qu'on fait et ce qui est aussi à
la base de la crise autour de l' la
faiblesse oui mais la faiblesse de la
commission c'est que les gouvernements
ont voulu ce ce président de la
commission exactement mais euh
normalement une un président de la
commission la Commission européenne a le
droit d'initiative c'est le seul
instance européenne qui peut le faire
qui peut déposer des projets qui peut
déposer des textes législatifs elle ne
le fait pas pour le moment elle attend
d'abord le feu vert de Paris et de
Berlin avant de bouger alors que dans
cette crise il faut des gens avec des
visions avec des
réformes très radicales pour sa l'UR
c'est ça qui manque pour le moment vous
avez pris les devants en tout cas est-ce
que vous seriez prêt éventuellement à
vous présenter sous une bannière
purement fédérale non moi je me non non
ça c'est l'idée de Guy moi je ne me
représenterai
pas sauf si y avait cette élection au
suffrage universel du président de la
commission ce qui ne sera pas le cas
parce qu'il faudrait changer rapidement
mais je dis simplement que aujourd'hui
il faut avancer dans une procédure où il
y a plus de légitimation
prés la moi j'essaie de rassembler tous
les proeuropéens pour se battre en 2014
parce que finalement je crois que ce
sont seulement les citoyens qui peuvent
faire changer cette Europe dans la bonne
direction est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment tous les deux que votre livre
qui a été publié déjà il y a quelques
semaines qui est d'ailleurs traduit dans
de plus en plus de langues au niveau
européen je crois qu'il maintenant 11
langues est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment déjà que c'est en train de
faire bouger un peu les
lignes parle quand même c'est c'est
c'est c'est oui la preuve on fait mais
surtout que c'est c'est devenu un un un
débat ouvert aussi dans le Parlement
européen de ceux qui disent non c'est
trop radical et cetera et et et nous qui
disons non c'est c'est la seule voie
réaliste parce que ceux qui disent que
c'est de l'utopie ou c'est irréaliste de
présenter cela c'est la situation
actuelle qui est qui n'est pas réaliste
de penser qu'on peut sortir de la crise
autour de l'euro et de la crise
économique par par des demi mesures
comme on a vu les trois dernières années
moi je vous je vous fais un Paris
François Hollande va parler au Parlement
européen en novembre ou en décembre je
sais pas quoi ben vous serez surpris
parce qu'il devra dire quelque chose sur
l'Europe et en fin de compte évidemment
qu'il ne citera pas mais il devra
répondre aux questions aux propositions
qu'on fait dans ce Liv je crois que les
responsables politiques ne peuvent pas
échapper au débat qu'on a lancé il y a
quand même eu des beaucoup de progrès
fait avec la mise en place d'un
mécanisme européen de sauvetage d'une
union bancaire
r pi LAN un contrôle budétaire pour
éviter que les pays fent ce qu'il
veulent dans le coin ça oui mais
regardez un peu regardez la supervision
bancaire il y a 2 ans le Parlement
européen le
présente l'allem dit jamais jamais 2 ans
après ou là là maman on a fait une
erreur on a perdu trop de temps on
aurait pu les faire plus vite per du
temps parce que justement on n pas de
boussole donc on réagit on réagit face à
la réalité qui nous nous impose des
décisions au lieu d'être maître de la
stratégie de nos décisions c'est que
vous dites que l'Europe maintenant doit
cesser de réagir aux événements et doit
prendre doit avoir une boussole une
orientation on y va on y va suppose ça
suppose aussi que le Parlement européen
soit écouté donc il ait encore plus de
de pouvoir ça supp passe que le
Parlement euréin joue son rôle il est en
train sur le budget il est en train de
jouer son rôle il est il met devant ses
responsabilité le Conseil européen et le
tant que le Parlement européen a une
majorité unie pas tout les pas mais une
majorité unie et bien ce Parlement peut
changer les choses et bien merci ce sera
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous sur le plateau d'Europe
Hebdo bien merci messieur d'avoir
accepté notre invitation debout l'Europe
c'est donc le titre de votre ouvrage
c'est également tout un programme quant
à nous on se retrouve ici la semaine
prochaine pour Europe Hebdo d'ici là
bonne suite de programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires